c'est jour de noces à la législature de
saint pétersbourg sur le parvis des
jeunes couples respire le bonheur d'une
nouvelle vie remplie de projets ils
devraient tous en bon citoyen revenir
ici dimanche pour voter mais ruslana et
dennis se demande si geste en vaut
vraiment la peine quand je dis non
ce sentiment d'impuissance qui nourrit
l'apathie politique en russie à la
veille des élections législatives
à quoi bon me tenir tête au pouvoir
quand on sait que le statut pour va
triompher comme d'habitude
que vaudrait maurice qui est candidat
pour le parti
encore le droit d'exister ici quoique
cette année les autorités ont déployé
des moyens extraordinaires pour limiter
ses chances de percer
boris affronte non pas un mais deux
autres beaux gosses vichnievsky même nom
même barbe même allure bref des saisies
pour semer la confusion aux yeux
c'est ça qui distingue cette élection
des autres dit il le niveau de
malhonnêteté états sont
ces jeunes sont venus le soutenir avec
l'humour qu'inspire ses tactiques
absurde mais complètement légale en
russie
bien que sur papier les électeurs aient
le choix tous ces partis sont alliés du
pouvoir ou approuvés par le kremlin les
candidats indépendants qui avaient des
véritables chances de gagner ont presque
tous été banni du scutin forcé à l'exil
ou jetés en prison
au mono opposition
des
métas yona et quand même mobilisé
nous l'avons rencontré à moscou elle
fait campagne pour l'opposant andré piva
borov un prisonniers politiques arrêtés
en juin dernier alors qu'il songeait à
se lancer dans la course si la
commission électorale a approuvé la
candidature d'un prisonnier c'est
qu'elle en profite aussi pour désormais
déclaré le parti iabloko agents
étrangers
une étiquette qui sert dorénavant
d'épouvantail pour à peu près n'importe
quelle voix dissidentes ou critiques du
gouvernement dit
pour valentina et d'anis voter c'est
exercer leur dernier droit
park a travaillé ce sont d'ailleurs les
gens en ont marre de la corruption et de
voir leur qualité de vie s'est traité de
nice mais tous les deux ne se font pas
d'illusions
valentina quittait observatrice aux
dernières élections c'est très bien ce
qui se passe en coulisses quand le vent
tourne contre le gouvernement
on nous demande de quitter la pièce pour
le décompte final et cette année et sera
pire tels carlos 6e a décidé de ne pas
envoyer d'observateurs étrangers étant
donné les restrictions que lui
imposaient les autorités russes c'est
dans ce climat que nous irons aux urnes
cet étudiant vivant
[Musique]
d'où l'importance d'aller voter pour
dire que bien que désenchanté leur
génération boc continue de se bat